ce
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin sur notre antenne à l'examen d'une
proposition de loi en faveur du
développement de l'alternance
objectif de ce texte améliorer la
situation de l'emploi des jeunes et
aussi favoriser leur insertion sur le
marché du travail
il faut dire que la catégorie des 16 25
ans est particulièrement touchée par le
chômage puisque le taux de chômage
atteint 23 3% pour cette tranche d'âge
pour sylvie desmarescaux sénatrice non
inscrits du nord et rapporteur de ce
texte
cette proposition de loi contient des
dispositions concrètes efficaces qu'il
faut mettre en oeuvre rapidement tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle du
sénat très bonne séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée dont le
développement de l'alternance
je vous parle on est la sécurisation des
parcours professionnels dans la
discussion générale la part en l'état
madame nadine morano ministre chargée de
l'apprentissage et de la formation
professionnelle vous avez la parole
madame la ministre
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteure mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
je souhaite tout d'abord rendre hommage
à l'engagement historique disons le du
sénat sous l'impulsion de son président
gérard larcher pour promouvoir
l'apprentissage
le sénat se mobilisent depuis longtemps
avec force et conviction pour améliorer
l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
et changer le regard des français sur
ces formations en mai 2010 les
rencontres sénatoriales de
l'apprentissage ont par exemple permis
d'ouvrir les portes du sénat à 160
jeunes apprentis français et allemand je
pense aussi à l'organisation de la
cérémonie de remise des médailles d'or
du concours national
un des meilleurs apprentis de france et
du trophée de l'apprentissage à laquelle
j'ai participé le 23 février dernier
je tiens également évidemment à
remercier le rapporteur madame sylvie
demarescaux de cette proposition de loi
pour le développement de l'alternance et
de la sécurisation des parcours
professionnels
avec ce texte notre pays va se doter du
cadre législatif nécessaire au
développement des formations par
alternance
il témoigne de la mobilisation des
parlementaires et démontre une nouvelle
fois que l'emploi des jeunes et la
priorité de la majorité
je veux aussi saluer les membres de la
commission des affaires sociales en
particulier sa présidente muguette dini
qui malgré délais des délais
particulièrement courts ont effectué un
travail important et des auditions de
qualité sur ce texte le gouvernement
vous le savez est très attachée au
respect de votre travail parlementaire
votre expertise et les idées qui émane
directement de votre expérience du
terrain sont indispensables dans le
combat que nous menons en faveur de
l'emploi l'emploi des jeunes doit être
un objectif national partagé
nous avons le devoir d'être à la hauteur
des attentes de la jeunesse pour lui
permettre de s'intégrer pleinement à
notre société en ayant la possibilité
d'accéder à un travail qui assure une
réelle autonomie matérielle
financière en 2007 le président de la
république la place est d'ailleurs au
coeur de son projet politique
la réhabilitation de la valeur travail
depuis cette date et malgré la crise
financière cet objectif a toujours guidé
l'action du gouvernement
à travers cette proposition je me
réjouis de voir que nous allons
transcrire dans notre droit à la fois
les engagements du président de la
république qu'il a énoncées lors de son
discours du 1er mars à bobigny certaines
propositions également de l'accord
national interprofessionnel des
partenaires sociaux sur l'emploi des
jeunes du 17 jours du 7 juin pardon 2011
ainsi que les conclusions du groupe de
travail sur l'emploi constitué par
christian jacob et auquel jean claude
car philippe dominati et alain gournac
ont participé
la feuille de route qui nous a été
confiée par le président de la
république est très clair développer les
formations par alternance pour obtenir
pour atteindre l'objectif de 800000
alternants d'ici à 2015 ces formations
sont un véritable prêt-à-l'emploi
monsieur le sénateur elles sont une
garantie d'insertion professionnelle et
vous le savez rapide et durable avec de
perspectives véritables perspectives de
progression sociale
je le rappelle 80% des jeunes apprentis
ont un emploi à l'issue de leur diplôme
je souhaite d'abord aussi rétablir la
vérité sur ce texte concernant l'âge
d'entrée en apprentissage affirmé que le
gouvernement la majorité parlementaire
veulent autoriser l'apprentissage à 14
ans est à la fois démagogique faut tenir
un tel discours ne peut venir que d'une
intention manifeste de déformer la
réalité en matière d'âge d'entrée en
apprentissage il faut rappeler les faits
notre droit prévoit déjà l'entrée des
jeunes en apprentissage avant 16 ans
mais pour protéger les jeunes
deux conditions doivent être remplies
avoir achevé le premier cycle de
l'enseignement secondaire le collège et
avoir au moins 15 ans au moment de la
signature du contrat
ces conditions ont été fixées par une
circulaire du 30 mai 1997 et non jamais
été supprimée par la gauche lorsqu'elle
était au pouvoir
le problème est que cette règle est
source de difficultés lourdes
il est inutile pour de nombreux jeunes
qui ont suivi une scolarité sans accroc
mais qui est en est entre septembre et
décembre
noront 15 ans qu après la rentrée
scolaire que doit-on conseillé à ces
jeunes
redoublez perdre un an
renoncer un emploi futur grâce à
l'apprentissage modifier une législation
qui n'est plus adapté c'est faire preuve
de pragmatisme d'ambition pour la
jeunesse et surtout de courage politique
c'est tout le sens de cette proposition
de loi
concrètement avec ce texte dès lors
qu'un jeune aura fini sa classe de
troisième il pourra s'inscrire en
apprentissage
même s'il est né après le mois de
septembre la règle sera l'anel sur
l'ensemble du territoire
un jeune qui sera à moins de trois mois
de son 15e anniversaire n'aura pas à
attendre un an après sa troisième pour
devenir apprenti
je souhaite maintenant détaillé les
principaux apports de ce texte pour
inciter les jeunes à s'engager vers
l'apprentissage
il faut revaloriser le statut de
l'apprenti une carte d'étudiant des
métiers sera donc délivré par le cfa et
permettra l'apprenti d'accéder aux mêmes
réductions tarifaires que les étudiants
de l'enseignement supérieur je sais cher
catherine procaccia combien cette mesure
à l'élaboration de laquelle vous êtes
associé vous importe je le dis même si
elle n'est pas présente dans l'hémicycle
parce qu'il faut également faciliter les
relations entre les employeurs et les
alternant ainsi que la vie des
entreprises
ce texte prévoit la création d'un
service dématérialisé de l'alternance
parmi les autres apports de cette
proposition moi je veux citer aussi la
possibilité nouvelle est indispensable
pour deux employeurs saisonniers
d'embaucher un apprenti en signant une
convention tripartite avec lui ou encore
l'ouverture de l'apprentissage aux
entreprises intérimaire c'est faire
preuve
évidemment de pragmatisme et répondre à
la tente du terrain de même un employé
un salarié pour désormais renouveler un
contrat de professionnalisation dès lors
que la qualification permet d'améliorer
le détenu par le salarié par ailleurs
l'instauration d'un cadre légal pour les
stages de découverte en entreprise
proposée par certaines chambres
consulaires pendant les vacances
scolaires est une avancée importante
pour mettre les jeunes en relation avec
le monde professionnel
grâce au travail de la commission des
affaires sociales et de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation de la
communication de nouvelles avancées ont
été apportées à ce texte depuis son vote
à l'assemblée nationale mardi dernier
par l'amendement de madame la présidente
muguette dini les particuliers
employeurs vont pouvoir recourir aux
contrats de professionnalisation
sous réserve qu'ils bénéficient d'un
accompagnement adapté aux besoins de
leur statut c'est une avancée importante
pour ce secteur porteur d'emplois et
d'activités non délocalisables cela
aussi sert à assurer l'avenir s'agissant
de l'accès des apprentis ou baccalauréat
professionnel
le travail du sénat permet d'instaurer
un véritable système dit du 1 + 2 afin
d'adapter l'apprentissage au
baccalauréat professionnel en trois ans
jusqu'à maintenant alors que les lycéens
pouvaient effectuer une seconde
professionnelle général et se déterminer
ensuite pour un certificat d'aptitude
professionnelle ou à baccalauréat
professionnel
les apprentis devait arrêter leur choix
dès la signature du contrat
d'apprentissage
l'article 6 tel qu'il a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale permet aux
apprentis de bénéficier de la même
souplesse que les lycéens mais
l'amendement présenté par monsieur le
président jacques le genre monsieur jean
claude carle madame pro cassia et madame
colette mélot permet d'aller encore plus
loin
désormais les apprentis tout en étant en
contrat d'apprentissage pourront suivre
une année de préparation générale à
l'issue de laquelle ils s'engageront
soit vers un certificat d'aptitude
aptitudes professionnelles soit vers un
baccalauréat professionnel
cette proposition de loi s'inscrit aussi
et je le dis dans la révolution
culturelle que nous sommes en train de
mener xavier bertrand et moi même pour
valoriser l'apprentissage afin de
conduire cette révolution des mesures
concrètes ont été prises pour les
entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
deux dispositifs sont effectives depuis
le 1er mars
la compensation zéro charge pendant un
an pour toute embauche supplémentaire
d'un
jeunes en apprentissage ou en contrat de
professionnalisation
la prime de 2000 euros pour inciter les
entreprises à conclure je le rappelle
des contrats de professionnalisation
pour les personnes de plus de 45 ans de
même la hausse de 3 à 4 % du quota
d'alternants pour les entreprises de
plus de 250 salariés a été actée vous
savez dans le cadre de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour 2011 nous avons décidé de prendre
en compte la piste proposée par les
partenaires sociaux dans l'accord
national interprofessionnel des jeunes
afin de mieux accompagner et de
valoriser les branches professionnelles
qui s'engagent et qui ont des résultats
parce que je sais que l'action de l'état
a aussi besoin de relais j'ai organisé
le 27 avril une grande journée de
mobilisation avec plus de 60
représentants des branches
professionnelles des engagements
ambitieux ont été pris
le secteur du paysage prévoit
d'atteindre 10 % d'alternants par an
soit 7 mai apprentis les secteurs du
commerce de gros et de détail visent
respectivement +10 et +8 de contrats de
professionnalisation pour aller encore
plus loin dans la mobilisation des
entreprises
j'organise demain une réunion d'échangé
et de travail avec les entreprises du
cac 40 qui signeront une charte en
faveur du développement de l'alternance
avec des engagements précis parce qu'il
est temps de changer le regard que notre
pays porte sur l'apprentissage
j'ai aussi créé le 7 avril le club de
l'apprentissage dans le but de
sensibiliser les jeunes et leurs
familles ce club est animé par des
anciens apprentis devenus des références
dans leur métier comme le coiffeur
franck provost ou guy savoy
par ailleurs j'ai lancé une communauté
d'apprentissage sur le site viadeo pour
mettre en relation les apprentis les
entreprises et leur centre de formation
allez xavier bertrand nous avons lancé
le 5 mai dernier une grande campagne
nationale de promotion de
l'apprentissage sur les radios un métier
un diplôme un revenu c'est ça
l'apprentissage avec cette campagne nous
avons vous nous avons voulu dire aux
jeunes que l'apprentissage est une voie
royale vers l'emploi est un moteur de
promotion sociale
accessible à tous les niveaux de
formation et dans tous les secteurs en
trois semaines de campagne
pas loin de 200 mille connexions au lieu
sur le site internet emploie point
gouv.fr preuve s'il en était que les
familles et les jeunes se sont senti
intéressé est interpellé par cette
campagne
s'agissant des contrats d'objectifs et
de moyens pour l'apprentissage les comme
2011 2015
je viens je veille avec les avis
bertrand ce que toutes les régions
prennent leurs responsabilités et
s'engage à parité avec l'état le 1er
juin
j'ai signé avec le président de la
région languedoc roussillon le premier
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens à
parité 70 millions d'euros pour la
région 70 millions d'euros pour l'état
avec la perspective de 22500 apprentis
soit une augmentation de 47% lundi
dernier j'étais en bourgogne avec
françois patriat vendredi en alsace et
je serai jeudi en lorraine pour signer
avec ces régions les accords cadres en
faveur du développement de
l'apprentissage c'est la preuve que tous
les acteurs peuvent s'unir dans une
démarche républicaine
au delà des clivages politiques dès lors
que l'intérêt des jeunes prévaut au
total l'état consacre 1,7 milliard
d'euros au financement des comme
2011-2015 pour permettre aux jeunes de
bénéficier d'un appareil de formation
performant et d'avoir accès à des
solutions d'hébergement ses 350 millions
d'euros de plus par rapport à la
première génération de contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens
c'est également tout le sens de l'appel
à projets doté de 500 millions d'euros
dans le cadre du programme
d'investissements d'avenir dont le
déploiement avance très bien
le premier ministre a en effet annoncé
le 23 mai dernier quatre projets quatre
premiers projets retenus qui vont
bénéficier d'une enveloppe de 19
millions d'euros
je rappelle que sur le grand emprunt
nous consacrons à la fois sur 50 appels
à projets d'ici à 2014 la rénovation ou
la création de centres de formation
innovant
deneault ces femmes + 15000 places
d'hébergement dans notre pays
de nombreux jeunes n'arrivent pas à
accéder à un emploi durable
c'est trop souvent le cas y compris pour
certains jeunes qui ont suivi des
formations exigeante dans le système
scolaire et universitaire classique
face à ces solutions parfois très
difficile à vivre sur le plan humain et
familial
nous ne devions pas baisser les bras
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui cette
proposition de loi
nous avec cette proposition de loi nous
affirmons notre ambition pour notre
jeunesse et nous donnons les moyens de
développer des solutions mieux adaptées
aux réalités actuelles et aux acteurs et
techniques onomique l'avenir de notre
pays
l'avenir de nos jeunes se construit ici
même et avec vous sur les bancs de cet
hémicycle
nous devons en être pleinement
conscients et surtout fier parce que
nous donnons des perspectives à notre
jeunesse je vous remercie de votre
attention je vous remercie madame la
ministre à parole est à mme monsieur
aviez bertrand ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de la santé
madame le ministre
un chat nadine supprimer d'un président
de la commission des affaires sociales
madame la rapporteure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
ensemble aujourd'hui nous permet
d'apporter des réponses concrètes pour
développer l'emploi des jeunes l'emploi
des jeunes vous le savez la priorité du
gouvernement rappelait par le prieur de
la république parce que très clairement
au delà des discours un pays qui
n'offrent pas d'avenir à ces jeunes
c'est un pays qui tout simplement n'a
pas d'avenir et je crois nous en sommes
toutes et tous convaincus ici je
remercie la rapporteure sylvie
desmarescaux pour le travail de grande
qualité qui a été effectué en commission
et qui a permis
je le dis de richir ce texte je voudrais
associer bien sûr à ses remerciements la
présidente muguette dini
cette proposition de loi proposant de
développer l'alternance d'encadrer des
stages de développer l'emploi dans les
groupements d'employeurs et de sécuriser
les parcours professionnels grâce au
dispositif unique d'insertion des
salariés licenciés pour motif économique
je vais pas revenir longuement sur les
dispositions concernant l'alternance
nadine morano l'a fait en détails et je
veux la remercier tout particulièrement
de l'implication qu'elle témoigne dans
ce dossier essentiel pour nos jeunes
concernant l'alternance vous le savez si
vous voulez des résultats en matière
d'emploi des jeunes il faut rapprocher
des jeunes de l'entreprise parce qu'un
jeune qui apprend son métier en même
temps en entreprise et à l'école a
beaucoup plus de chances de trouver un
emploi en sus ensuite j'en veux pour
preuve que plus de 8 jeunes sur 10
formés en alternance trouvent un emploi
dans l'année et ce n'est pas jean claude
carle spécialiste de cette question
depuis bien longtemps qui me démentira
je le pense l'objectif que nous a fixé
le prix de la république est d'atteindre
le nombre de 808 alternant dont 600
milles apprentis d'ici 2015 nous avons
aujourd'hui 420 milles apprentis pour
atteindre cet objectif nous avons déjà
pris des mesures importantes a dit mme
morano les a rappelé les aides pour les
pme le relèvement du quota les
partenaires sociaux veulent aussi
s'engager notamment à travers les
branches pour développer l'alternance on
ne peut que soutenir cette dynamique en
veillant bien sûr à ce qu'elles
permettent à tous de progresser vers cet
objectif de 800 mille alternant 2015
nous avons d'ailleurs fait adopter un
amendement gouvernemental en ce sens
dans le plfr la semaine dernière les
modifications apportées par l'assemblée
nationale ont permis de trouver des
réponses par exemple pour adapter
apprentissage au bac professionnel en
trois ans avec des mesures pragmatiques
et efficaces qui seront opérationnels
dès cette rentrée 2011 la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat a voulu aller
plus loin encore et je soutiens ce
volontarisme
nous voulons aussi ramené leurs justes
proportions les interrogations exprimées
sur l'âge d'entrée en apprentissage
le texte permet simplement de prendre en
compte les jeunes dont la date
anniversaire des quinze ans tombe après
le début de l'année scolaire
et si vous avez un jeune qui a 15 ans le
2 novembre
on lui demande d'attendre quoi dix mois
sans rien faire qui lui soit constructif
tout simplement parce qu'il n'a pas
atteint ses 15 ans voilà c'est juste
cela c'est juste en plus de légaliser
une pratique existante et qui permet
aussi ce texte d'élargir le pré
apprentissage sous statut scolaire pour
les jeunes ayant achevé leur troisième
il ne s'agit que de cela rien de plus
rien de moins
nous n'avons pas voulu poser un principe
général alors qu'il existe déjà je vous
le rappelez des dispositions sur
l'apprentissage junior dans le code de
l'éducation
nous avons voulu apporter des souplesses
de façon pragmatique et ceux qui
seraient dans un débat idéologique sur
ce dossier en seront pour leurs frais
j'en viens aux dispositions de la
proposition de loi qui vise à mieux
encadrer les stages en entreprises pour
empêcher les années l'assemblée
nationale a repris les dispositions de
l'accord national interprofessionnel du
7 juin qui encadre la pratique des
stages et je salue l'action conjuguée
des partenaires sociaux du parlement
pour atteindre cet objectif
l'action du gouvernement a permis des
progrès mais nous ouvrons je le pense
une nouvelle étape avec ces dispositions
délai de carence plafonnement à 6 mois
interdiction de pouvoir un emploi lié à
l'activité permanente de l'entreprise
les stages permettent aux jeunes de
préciser l'orientation de mettre en
oeuvre des connaissances théoriques dans
un cadre professionnel d'acquérir une
expérience du monde de l'entreprise et
de ses métiers
c'est un moyen efficace d'insertion sur
le marché du travail il faut bien
veiller à ce que l'ue l'entreprise donne
le meilleur image d'elle-même la
meilleure image de même assez jeune ces
modalités vont nous permettre de le
garantir
troisième point ce texte comporte
également des dispositions pour faire
franchir un cap au groupement
d'employeurs ces groupements sont un
atout pour l'entreprise
parce qu'ils permettent des embauches
qui n'auraient pas pu se faire si chaque
entreprise avait dû assumer seul la
charge administrative ou le coût de
l'embauché d'un salarié supplémentaire
les groupements d'employeurs sont aussi
un avantage pour le salarié qui peut
ainsi exercer son métier dans
différentes entreprises et enrichir son
expérience
les entrepreneurs qui utilisent ce
système notamment dans les zones
touristiques là où il a été expérimenté
en priorité ont fait part de leur
satisfaction vis-à-vis de ce dispositif
qui est un dispositif empirique mais
nous pouvons aujourd'hui aller plus loin
nous voulons aller plus loin jean
charles taugourdeau député s'est
spécialisé sur cette question depuis
longtemps et et nous a permis aussi
d'inscrire dans la loi des modalités